I think every single photo that's edited  should have to have a sign somewhere  saying edited like I opened up recently  about getting caught photoshopping I was  feeling really insecure about my body it  was my birthday I was having fun in Las  Vegas oh there it is thanks guys  um and I had I had an insecure moment  and I cinched in my waist and when I got  called out for it which I love that is  my relationship with my listeners is  they I hold them accountable they hold  me accountable in that moment I was like  we why did I do that maybe if I with my  platform openly say  I'm done every photo you now see of me  going forward I will not Photoshop that  will inspire others to be a little bit  more authentic because again it's like  who are we doing this for I completely  agree thank you so much